here's what would happen if the earth  was spinning on its side  four and a half billion years ago our  earth got slammed by thea a mars-sized  proto-planet shifting its axis 70  degrees from its orbital axis over time  this decrease to the 23 and a half  degree tilt we know today  a 90 degree actual tilt would eliminate  seasons as we know them imagine a six  month winter followed by a six month  summer  not so bad well think again in the  northern hemisphere you'd be getting 80  to 100 degree summers that could boil  water in winter well have fun driving  through blizzards in florida the extreme  weather on a sideways earth would give  us a shorter harvest season for food  push coastal cities underwater and leave  places like europe uninhabitable  this would spell disaster for humanity  so